[Music]
have you heard of Bali have you tried it
if you have watched my 11 hike up fruits
you should be eating you would have
learned that if this underrated green
it's one of the world's oldest super
foods and it's loaded with all the
essential nutrients Valley water is an
incredible drink which our ancestors
included in their daily diet when I was
growing up I remember drinking barley
water on a regular basis if you can swim
badly on a regular basis it will keep
your colon and intestines happy it will
control your blood cholesterol levels
you will maintain your skin elasticity
and you will strengthen your immune
system plus is extremely affordable Bali
contains about 62% of dietary fiber and
you will be getting 20 to 25% of your
daily fiber in just one serving the best
way to use Bali is to simply treat it
like rice oats or any other greens you
can make stir-fry bali rice risotto
steel or soups or toss it into salads so
I'm gonna share with you four really
simple recipes which you can make for
breakfast lunch and also dinner let's
start with breakfast we got a barley
porridge on the menu it's really simple
in a small pot combine quarter cup of
pearl Valley with 3/4 cup of water and
bring it to a boil lower the heat and
simmer for about 20 to 30 minutes until
the water has been absorbed and barley
is completely soft then stir in about
half a cup of milk and allow it to
simmer very quickly until you get your
desired consistency remove from heat
so I've served my with one sliced banana
1 tablespoon of apricot seeds and about
1 teaspoon of chia seeds you can choose
to drizzle with a little bit of honey
having a fiber rich breakfast will keep
you going till lunchtime
so each Bowl has about 460 calories the
chewy and tender texture of barley is
very similar to oatmeal plus it is very
easy to make
so you can stop your breakfast and
replace odds with barley
let's make lunch I have barley and
beaded salad on my menu for this recipe
you can use barley as a replacement for
rice couscous or quinoa salads are my go
to lunch because most of the ingredients
do not require cooking so what I've used
are one and a half cup of cooked barley
two cups of baby spinach 1/2 a cup of
public cabbage 2 bits cooked and sliced
about quarter cup of fresh mint leaves 2
tablespoons of feta cheese cubed 1 tbsp
of dried cranberries 1 tbsp of apricot
seeds about 1/2 a tbsp of olive oil 2
tablespoons of lemon juice and 1 tsp of
honey it's so simple all you have to do
is assemble all the vegetables together
then drizzle with olive oil lemon juice
and honey and serve you're getting the
earthy flavor from the beets combined
with the chewy body texture crunchiness
from the spinach and cabbage and tangy
nurse from the feta cheese it is so
simple it's delicious and is so colorful
and each serving only has about 314
calories lunch is about keeping it
simple quick and healthy so try this
recipe out and choose any other
vegetables of your choice and with the
leftover body here's another really
simple lunch you can put together stir
fry barley rice with on the rise of
course what I've used are 1 and 1/2 cups
of cooked barley 1 medium carrot diced
about half a cup of mushrooms sliced 1/2
a red bell pepper diced 1 and a half
cups of cabbage shredded one whole
zucchini diced half a head of broccoli
cut into florets 2 cloves of garlic
crushed 1 tablespoon of olive oil 2
tablespoons of soy sauce and salt and
pepper to taste in a pan heat oil over
medium-high heat then stir in all the
vegetables garlic mushrooms carrots
zucchinis red bell pepper
broccoli and cabbage saute them very
quickly for three to four minutes then
mix in the barley soy sauce and also
salt and pepper to taste
toss all the ingredients thoroughly
until they are well combined
this dish is delicious warm or chilled
and each serving only has about 314
calories packing in lots of vegetables
is the key to keeping your fried rice
healthy plus you're getting your rainbow
I wanted as something comforting for
dinner so I'm making barley and beef
stew for this recipe you'll need 1/2 a
cup of pearl barley about 300 grams of
beef ribs let's prep all the vegetables
chop up one carrot a cup of celery a cup
of mushrooms and 1 onion in a pot melt
about half a tablespoon of butter over
medium high heat then sear the beef
pieces you want to season it with a
little bit of salt and pepper set aside
now in the same pot add in the chopped
onions and saute until fragrant and
slightly Brown just for about 5 to 6
minutes then stir in the mushrooms and
cook very quickly and is slightly tender
for about 2 to 3 minutes then add the
beef back into the pot add in about 2
cups of water and sprinkle with half a
teaspoon of dried basil then allow the
beef to gently simmer under low heat
until very tender for about 1 hour once
the beef is tender add in the remaining
ingredients barley celery and carrots
continue to cook all the ingredients
until they are very tender for at least
45 to 60 minutes now if you like your
meat a falling off the bone then cook
for another additional hour serve hot H
serving has about 418 calories and this
is a one pot dish so you can double up
the ingredients and cook it for a huge
family you can even choose to serve it
as a starter so try all these different
Valley recipes out let me know which is
your favorite in the comments
if you haven't yet tried Valley you have
to give this super grain a chance you
will love it you will love the chewy and
tender texture of Barney don't forget to
snap pictures tag me at Jonas official
and hashtag it chase your recipes to
like this video share this video and
subscribe to my youtube channel for a
lot more healthy and delicious recipes
do check out my workout challenges as
well okay so eat well stay healthy stay
active and all the best